c'est non non
[Musique]
pacé grand père
grâce à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse la femme moderne peut
désormais sortir la tête haute et le
ventre plat mais un nouveau pas vers
l'humanisation de la médecine peut
encore être franchies
je veux parler non plus de l' ivg mais
deux lives et l'interruption volontaire
de vieillesse voyez ce septuagénaire de
70 ans je m'emmerde
qu'attend t-il encore de la vie rien du
tout notre devoir
n'est-il point de pratiquer sur l'huile
iv v afin d'abréger son ennui si bien
sûr à une seule condition que
l'intéressé lui même donne son accord
alors monsieur vous êtes d'accord pour
que nous pratiquions sur vous
l'interruption volontaire de vieillesse
allons témoin s'est souvent merci de
toute façon reste un jeu là est certes
plus qu'ils disent etonnant non
[Musique]
etonnant non